play hard they play below the goal line and better
be ready to [Applause] compete R angle shot off
the side of the cage comes out to the right
point for sha Walker reflected out by Travis
connecting knocked down in the neutral zone by
deledio score what a shot they tip it from the
top of the right Circle just a minute 50 seconds
in Owen Tiffin with his fourth in the last three
games he gets into the neutral zone that forces
a turnover and then a quick play bedia moves It
Up watch the Quick Pass right there and all of a
sudden ends up in the back of the net beautiful
quick transition as Frost sets the table and tip
it I think he surprises the goenda off he does
he does but also too watch bedia watch his he he
goes right in the sight lines of could Frost and
bedo with the assists Frost coming off a two goal
game he's been in and out of the lineup save made
by poter Hart on Demetri orof uh I don't recall
that no a big Save By Heart Right bad save on PE
on this feed by stall to martinook sometimes you
need a little bit of luck on your side and now
the Hurricanes clear the Zone it's to the Flyers
and it's Shay gloved by heart there's Shay with a
drive after Flex Wily picked up by spov back out
for Shay he's been shooting the puck a lot more
in recent games for the flyers from the back end
he's been a real nice surprise for the Flyers so
far this year oh good save there redirect and Rod
bore admitted this morning that it's still a work
in progress with some of the new guys but there's
no doubt I think over the long Hall some of those
changes made in the off season is going to be
for the better say that a lot here in Carolina
yes they do still think one oh look out here
there's an opportunity for K turned aside by
heart leading the Zone this Puck has got to get
out try to make a quick little play hook the YY
with the quick stick and then he tries to go
blocker side and Hart with a beautiful stop
yeah big save for HART timely saves right trying
to beat Po and the Yi there and ran himself into
a little bit of trouble but as go tender bails him
out nation in front off the redirect from Drury of
heart Nation finds Drury the redirect stopped
by the Philadelphia goal tender uh including
North America uh and Canada we do an awful lot of
research in Canada as well F the C back out Garvis
from a shot that stopped and covered up another
feather in the cap of both the be foundation
and the National Hockey appreciate it you know
in hockey uh we might pick team but but cancer
doesn't pick a team we are all on one team in this
fight to achieve Victory maybe nobody else did but
Hart certainly knew he was there and he came up
with a big save there's delorier covered up under
five to play first period one nothing Flyers ow
K with the goal his 100th National Hockey League
point think about some of the saves we've seen in
this game and there's another one there for HART
Burns looking for the redirect not connect now
slaving with a drive that's gloved by Hart and
uh mov ends up getting hurt and play a lick here's
theier dropping it back off Cony moving in with a
shot set off the mask yeah another nice touch play
Here by Ki he he did it on the first goal as well
a nice little kick out to coutrier and then kkny
trying the short side and yeah you could tell that
was calculated by coov you can't get your glove
up so get your head on it that was an old school
style save there like Brian Bret no I never did
that Dominic hasik was the guy that started to do
that I never understood it okay I'm not saying us
in your head cuz you don't use it very often but
I'm saying positionally the way you were standing
you standing in a net I'm like wow there's some
some room down low there and we used to see those
type saves well you know what man it might have
came out you know the way I wanted to but you
know the goal Union well represented only chance
I'll get into the Hall of Fame is by visiting him
eleno stopped by ketov comes back out to zamula I
swore that would be the last time I play but I
got roped into another alumni game in January
in Philadelphia so who scored on you last year
oh everybody lend Clark you name them they got
him look towards the net C now back for connecting
unfortunately Cur was down on his knees there what
a play by Walker all started by the excellent
play bying of the period score redirected in
front by Cony two nothing Philadelphia well we
talked about the hard work of the Philadelphia
Flyers and this shift is absolutely a blueprint
wide initially on this ship and then he just
went Puck battles and they make plays look at his
breakdown defensively for Carolina stealer with
the shot pass on the ice and that's one of those
you just dream about B is a forward in front of
the net where this thing all you got to do is open
up that bottom hand and that's stick blade and you
elevate the puck and the fers are taking a page
out of Carolina's book early in this make sure
the turnovers aren't there and get more pucks to
the they went through a little stretch there for
about you know two minutes where they were you
know turning the puck over Carolina's going to
have that ability to be able to do it not sure why
the goal light is still on in behind for check off
but you're Carolina's going to give you problems
because they for check in the way that they play
but for the most part I mean this has been a a
really really impressive solid period for the
Flyers connecties 10th of the season from sealer
and Couer at 1902 let's not forget a couple of the
obviously big time saves by Carter Hart because
this oh jet for the big stop for the closing
seconds of the period Big Time save he's playing
for a poke check too edzo he's a right so he takes
it to his backand the stick is ready for a poke
check tippet sees that so he tries to go [Music]
great to see Harper here at the game tonight
second period is underway with the Flyers leading
the Hurricanes two nothing ow and tiet Travis K
the goal scorers for Philadelphia we're managing
the puck very well and in the last two or three
minutes the pliers kind of found their game again
and and is down three nothing Philadelphia Ryan
King first of the Season what a pass here by by
Shawn Walker talk about a quick developing
play moroff has it turns it over here comes
Walker makes the pass and then backhand
forehand roof shot by paling what a play
and a good play by lton too along the wall
eight on the alltime list and second among
defenseman thriling only our Keith Yandle
in the studio tonight Brady Shay in deep
dropping it back off across it comes for
Pepi NIS rwi pass Jay with a shot bur toide
by Hart another save made by Hart tough
angle shot kept Alive by stov back out it
comes for pesi he shoots wide fesov with it
K stopped by heart fers clear the puck down
ice all off up the left side here come
the Hurricanes back into the flyer
Zone D'Angelo back to cross score
Nation the hurricanes are on the
board f is about 45 seconds prior cier
turns down a breakaway pretty much and
it watch this PL pass by Tony
D'Angelo and N does exactly what
you need to do top shelf no chance
for heart looks like Crossfire and
inami press to the board by bedo he's had himself
a good night here's conect the across forcer with
a shot and the save by kov starts with the
play by couturier here just to kind of chip
it past to open space allows for the odd man
rush and trying to shoot it back where KET
wins over the Ducks Kings and now the Hurricanes
they will head home and host Vegas on Saturday
flyers and an eight game losing streak to
Carolina Philadelphia with a 3-1 victory